this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by upstart raycon liquid iv
hawthorne and keeps more on that later
let's get into the do
the honeydew with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here bringing it at you from the
night pants studios i am ryan sickler
ryan sickler.com
ryan sickler on all social media i just
want to say thank you the numbers are
growing the subscribers keep adding up
you guys are
uh really supporting the show thank you
so much please make sure you're
subscribed to the youtube you all like
to watch it subscribe to it
uh we're gonna be bringing some more
shows over there got some fun stuff
coming up
um let's see ryan sickler.com make sure
you subscribe to the email list
uh youtube we've already said we got the
time codes there and the patreon the
honeydew with you all
that is another audience that keeps
growing thank you for your support it's
five bucks a month you get video and
audio
weekly um and if you do sign up for a
year you actually
save on over a month of episodes so i do
know
60 a year is a lot of money for people
right now so those of you who have thank
you so much i know some of you are going
to eventually
we're gonna keep doing it so if you or
anyone you know has a story that needs
to be heard
submit at honeydewpodcast gmail.com the
honeydewpodcast.com is the website where
you can go get the merch
everything's there the night pants the
champion uh night pants nation sweats
are selling out right now the hoodies
all of it go there ryan sickler tees
it's all there
if you live in la and you need music
lessons you know i'll record here at the
santa monica music center you'll get
online lessons from local los angeles
musicians
uh so go to santa monicamusic.com use
the code honeydew they'll wave the
registration fee and they'll give you
one free lesson all right
now that that's out of the way uh this
show
as i say all the time we highlight the
low lights
uh these are the stories behind the
storytellers this week first time here
on the honeydew very excited i've been
trying to make this one happen for a
while ladies and gentlemen
please welcome the one and only jo koyo
hey welcome to the honeydew job i'm
excited thank you for that
that was hands down the longest
introduction of the same pod that you do
every week
hey i know you guys uh go to the youtube
and i just want to thank you and also
the subscribers
thank you for the subscribers the
honeydew
honeydew.com ryanstickler.com ryan
sickler
secular slicker you guys brian and
also you guys honeydew honeydew honeydew
all right uh the night pants uh the
hoodies
the hoodies and the night pants they're
gone but we're getting them back and
we'll sell them out again
and the coffee bugs uh yeah we do have
coffee mugs
thank you you know what i love you'll be
kind of cool if there's like that um
where it's it's so long that it does
that transition filter
and it's still you talking about other
stuff
yeah yeah we got honeydew slippers
anyways i gotta i got about five minutes
left and i've been working on this one
he's finally here let's give him four
and a half minutes to tell him
kiss my ass i've heard people's intros
on podcasts 15 minutes and they're still
not even hitting the contest
i had you on my pod and you know what i
said right when we said action
i said ryan sickler yeah then he went
and re-recorded the intro after for 20
minutes
buy my joe coy merch yeah i never say
that by the way
i want to talk to you told me a little
bit of something off off camera before
we're gonna get to but just tell me a
little bit about your upbringing i mean
i'm
such a fan i listen to your stand up i
know everybody is but what how many
how many um siblings do you have i have
you know i got my
my sister gemma who uh you know runs
my business right that's who we've been
contacted yeah so she's
she's uh she's adopted so we adopted her
and uh but you know she's we're like
this you know because we're only like a
a year apart so
how old were we went to high school
together how old was she when your
family adopted her
uh baby we adopted her when she was like
10 11 but it took us years to get her
it did it took like three years it was a
huge process so when she got here she
was like
i think they're almost 14. you know what
i mean and
um and we went to junior high school
together in high school and and
and and now she works for me and she's i
loved it
that's why i love you dude you keep it
in the family i love what you do with
your son
oh thank you yeah your shit's great dude
thank you you have her working with you
how many
and and how many other people and i have
a brother and then i have my uh
my other sister rowena they're half by
the way
they're so my mom was married before she
met my dad and then
and then yeah so she had two kids with
her first husband yes and then they
adopted and they also had me
so you're the last i'm the last oh okay
all right you're the baby then
i'm the baby all right yeah so uh and
i'm the i'm not
i guess i'm the halfer i'm the only
heifer so i'm half white half filipino
oh your dad's white yeah and uh
so yeah that's that that's that's the
cosmetic makeup of uh the herbert family
slash coy herbert okay who's coy
coy is my nickname for my aunt my aunt
called me joe coy but i went up as
herbert when i started in 89
i used to go it's my name i used to grow
up as joseph herbert
and people would laugh you know what i
mean you do open mics the
you know the mc whoever the [ __ ] mc
would be like make fun of the name you
know what i mean like
if i said my name or people would heckle
my name so it was always me with the
struggle with my name
and then uh not realizing i had a cool
nickname which is my aunt at the evelyn
she would always call me jokoy but she
would say like
with an accent so you don't think of a
nickname that would be
good for stage until i was like looking
for a different name
and that's when it hit you and then
that's when it hit me when i was at her
house and she goes through ahoy eat and
i go that's my name
i'm gonna go as joe coy and then that's
how that all started
yeah i'm glad i'm glad it happened
um because i didn't know it was gonna be
that catchy it was like it was a catchy
name but i literally was doing it
because i was getting tired of people
[ __ ] up my name or making fun of the
name
and just stupid so your mom but i think
herbert is cool
yeah yeah right mm-hmm that's why he's
so funny about it you [ __ ] like i
have pt
i have ptsd because of it i literally
have ptsd
like i literally like my last special i
finally talked about it
you know i mean i was just like herbert
and then i swear to god when i said it
someone laughed i goes
that's why i [ __ ] changed my name was
it justin
comedy or your whole life no no growing
up in school i didn't think any
everyone loved it everyone used to call
me herb you know what i mean i used to
go by herbert i loved it it was right
when i started comedy
like that would be like a bear it's
comedy sort of
brand new media [ __ ] you dude
especially like the upping you know like
you're doing open mics they're just
trying to find some
i get it but [ __ ] it was like ptsd dude
i used to hate
going to new open mics i'm like what's
your name like joe joseph
herbert like what what is that german
like no
bro just [ __ ] say my name just say my
name
it was like annoying and then yeah so
that's what that was all about
what um are you
are you close with all your siblings yes
all right so
are your mom and dad still together
no my mom remarried uh another soldier
by the name of sergeant
uh frederick harrison and i loved dad
was a soldier my dad was a soldier but
and then my stepdad uh
is a soldier that that dude okay that do
change my life this is why i love you
because
you because back when you did the crab
feast yeah you may or may not remember
you rolled over with the tesla and
everything you did the crab feast
and one of the things you talked about
because i was going through
um a split with my daughter's mother and
one of the things and i remem
yours resonated with me and your advice
and everything you talked about how
you're still good with your ex yeah that
you all vacation together
yeah you know i mean i'm about to start
a vacation with you because you're going
to be
with my ex yeah well you're going to be
my daughter's stepdad oh covered bro i
can't wait to fly first class with you
but what i'm trying to get at is
it's gonna be so much you're you're just
seeing one of those souls that's
welcoming versus who's this [ __ ] guy
i think yeah you know what i mean like
and it really changed my way of of
thinking and like just taking a deep
breath going okay
yeah we can figure out how to do this we
can figure out how to get along i got
i'm about a thousand
yeah but i think considering like two
people who got together and
intentionally had a human being and then
fell apart i think we'd do okay yeah i
mean i think we did okay
you know we're at the same age right i
think
yeah i'm older than you and uh and we
came at a time when we were kids
divorce was new like people think
divorce is like thank you that people
think divorce has been since
the beginning of time no divorce is new
and especially you and i
we're a product of the beginning stages
of divorce that's very interesting
yeah like you remember all the movies
and stuff they had like divorce
court and they had like uh tv shows and
then they uh you know cream reverse
cream
versus cream it was a new thing and i
remember being in third grade when my
parents started having a hard time and i
remember going it's so
funny you say this i remember going like
the one or two kids
at the time i knew who had gone through
this because back then
also eventually everyone i feel like my
parents
or my friends parents got divorced but
back then in third grade i don't i don't
remember even knowing any of that you
know
you're right it was it was a new thing
and
and and when you get taught because when
you're a kid you're literally getting
taught
you know i mean you absorb we're sponges
and uh
and i was absorbing all of that just the
[ __ ] hate and anger
and just seeing my mom go through so
much [ __ ]
uh you know i think my dad still doesn't
understand
like me not being able to wear socks
because my mom couldn't afford socks you
know what i mean
and it sucks like i try i try he
apologizes
in no way am i [ __ ] on my dad you
guys like i love my dad to death he's
made up for it he's apologized it's back
here oh yeah i forgot it was camera four
i love you dad
and uh i keep forgetting yeah yeah yeah
yeah
don't worry i'll do it yeah yeah please
it's hard to take direction with the
direction but the director is on the
other side of this wall
this is the first podcast i've ever ever
done where the
where the director is being on the wall
we're covered for we don't sit in the
same room and you hear him through the
vents
oh [ __ ] just cans with string
and go thanks bro count me in
um no uh but like you know mean like i
absorbed all that you know i
saw it man and and uh it was that whole
thing like oh
go get a lawyer if you want more you
know what i mean or let me hide it and
take me to court
i remember my mom you gotta remember my
mom's an immigrant that just came to
this country
you know i mean she doesn't know what
america is she's got a kid
she never knew what racism was she lived
with filipinos you know what i mean
you know i remember being half white
half asian and going up an escalator my
mom
saw a kid you know this is jcp jcpenney
we won this tv in a raffle
and it's just the oddest looking family
you know you got to remember i'm a doc
i'm half i got a sister that's adopted
and then i got another sister what's her
dark the ethnicity filipino okay and um
she's not i don't want you to think
she's black but she's she's a darker
olive you know what i mean so she didn't
look like us but we're a
little family unit going up this
escalator it's like 1983.
i still remember this bro and my mom
loves kids and she's like oh hi
she's looking at this kid hello oh my
god so cute she went like that
and then the kid went like this he went
and then turned back around
whoa and i remember oh and i remember
like looking
i didn't even know what that was you
know when you live on a base
bro you you know all you see are mixed
kids
that's why when when 89 came out and
tiger woods was so [ __ ] big
people didn't know how to react i
remember getting mad not in the 89 i was
like 91.
but i remember everyone getting mad like
because he said uh
i'm not full black my mom is still thai
like i remember him saying something
like that and then there was all these
jokes and people making fun of it
because i don't think people really knew
how to react to that they didn't know
what a
a mixed kid was yet you know what i mean
and i
i know that hands-on because i was a
part of that you know
uh and uh and seeing that because i was
so used to being on the base all we had
were mixed kids
black and german kids mexican asian kids
yeah
white and crazy yeah it's just so crazy
like we're in our own little bubble
and then when you go out into the real
world and and here's my mom who's only
you know
she she's in america now she's got this
mixed
kid and a full filipino kid yeah and and
then that happening and i remember my
mom this is how cool my mom was she was
like don't worry joe he does it no
like i thought that was cool because she
could have been mad yeah she could be
like [ __ ] you huh
you know what i mean [ __ ] you you [ __ ]
you you kids
you [ __ ] kids and your parents are
[ __ ]
your parents are [ __ ] beat you that huh
[ __ ] you
jc penny [ __ ] with the tv you just
want oh the scene would kill you bro
and i know why that i know why that
family was mad because we literally
sat at that raffle for probably two
hours did i tell you this story
we i swear to god we needed a color tv
so bad bro
we filled out every single you know how
they leave stacks yeah yeah yeah
take one and fill up [ __ ] all of
us
everybody every single one of us my
brother my sister
gemma just came to this country isn't
this illegal
is this okay it says take one just shut
the [ __ ] up look at the tv
shut up and win this tv and we crammed
it i know everyone was mad they everyone
saw us doing it
but uh and we won the tv man and i and
we were going up to claim it but uh and
when that kid did that man it that to
this day i still remember it yeah
but uh but that was the times we lived
in right we absorb all that [ __ ]
and uh and i i could have easily uh went
that route
you know that's what i'm saying so
before i we get to
all the way to that question what then
was it like
leaving this bubble on this base and
really stepping into the world like what
did you
what did you experience in your lifetime
well you know i
i lived in tacoma it was depressing like
what age do you get off the base
or do you go through high school like
eleven okay eleven two or middle school
you're getting yeah and now you're going
into regular publishing
yeah now i see what regular in
washington yeah okay now i see what it
is
right it's so crazy even this is my
first time even talking about this
this yeah yeah because i didn't really
realize that i was always
military life for the first 11 years of
my life well you're blowing my mind with
hearing about black and german kids and
stuff and i'm thinking oh yeah military
kids come from around the world
it would make sense that these two
people get together and this is the
offspring it's it's probably so diverse
and
i i i always say this uh on stage
ryan i i always go thank god for the
military because they created the mixed
race
they really did they they hammered that
down bro
you're right about that that seriously
vietnamese black
are you gonna be ty white filipino white
black chinese black korean white dude
like those are my friends i just named
off like
a bunch of my friends right there and uh
and i still remember them to this day
like you know and then when you go
you know now now we live in a time like
my son only all he sees are mixed kids
but
it's hard for me to explain what i went
through the last 20 years
30 years was yeah yeah i know what
racism is
indirectly in that and and you know like
i hate saying it because my dad i love
my dad so much bro
because he he went against the grain you
know i mean he's a white
family herbert it doesn't get anything
yeah buffalo new york what yeah you know
what i mean where white people thrive in
the snow
they're only white you know i mean
that's it and uh
what's a bill what's a bill
buffalo bill you know what their
cheerleaders are called
jills jills yeah jill's the bills and
the jills
get the [ __ ] out so what it is but i
love my dad because he joined the
military
went to asia saw what an asian woman
looked like it was like
blow his mind
[ __ ] jill
[Laughter]
oh
himself a kid so wait does your dad um
does he i don't know the backstory okay
you don't know they married
i don't think were they married here in
the states or oh no they were married
abroad okay
but but they were married to misawa
japan because he was you know he kept
moving
uh and so i'm i was born in misawa but
i don't know the backstory nor do i wish
to know okay
all i know is that i give my dad kudos
to be
28 27
and then getting a woman pregnant and
becoming a
and being a man and you know yo he could
have easily just got on a goddamn plane
to move back
yeah you know i mean he could have done
it bro it's not that hard
and he didn't and so did a lot of people
but let me put this
on your plate bro this is why i respect
my dad even though you know he [ __ ] up
dad
wait you [ __ ] up
but but i i appreciate him because he
what he did was
he i don't know if she i don't know how
it was but
imagine ryan being 27 27-28
mind you this is 60s you know military
we're fighting a war
yeah racism is huge
you have white you have white-skinned
blue eyes right
and now you just got an asian woman
pregnant
you know and she also has two kids
that's right she had two kids already a
four-year-old and an
eight-year-old mm-hmm
and the dude married her bro
i don't know what what what soldiers
make now he was probably a
airman first class at that point 28.
what did i i don't even know what the
pay scale is google it what is it 300 a
month i mean
with free housing you know what i mean
but now five miles to feed five yeah how
like
yo i always say that like yeah my dad
divorced my mom
[ __ ] up can i ask are you comfortable
talking about
how he [ __ ] up dude this is crazy i'm
even talking about this now this is all
my first time saying this really yeah
you've never talked about divorce but
like
this this deep little middle circle
right here is
like some details that i've never really
expressed so what i do this is what we
do on the dude
you didn't really do much you said my
name
is so yeah yeah you gave me a cup
but uh i'm the one spilling the beans
[Laughter]
let's take a quick break and tell you
about our first sponsor upstart now
there's a lot of economic chatter right
now about the state of the market is it
recovering how long will it take have we
seen the worst but if you're struggling
to pay off your high interest credit
card debt
you can't wait for those answers you
need to take action now with upstart
there's actually something you can do
today
to help fight off high interest credit
card debt upstart is the revolutionary
online lending platform
that knows you're more than just a
credit score unlike other lenders
upstart can reward you based on your job
history in the form of a smarter rate
upstart lets you skip going to the bank
because it's completely online they
offer loans from one thousand dollars
all the way up to 50 000 so you can
consolidate your debt
into one easy fix rate payment upstart
makes it fast and simple to check your
rate since it's just a soft
pull it will not affect your credit
score alright the hard pull happens if
you accept your rate you proceed with
your application and the best part
is if the loan is approved and accepted
most people are getting their funds
the very next business day over 500 000
people views upstart to pay off credit
cards
or meet their financial goals i know you
guys are out there doing it you hit me
up about it you tell me how great it is
and if you notice upstart keeps coming
back free yourself from the burden of
high interest credit card debt and get
back to using
your money your way with upstart see why
upstart has over 6 000
five-star reviews on trustpilot and
hurry to upstart.com
honeydew to find out how low your
upstart rate can be
checking your rate only takes a few
minutes that's upstart.com
honeydew our next sponsor or my favorite
headphones raycon all right so here's
another way 2020 is throwing us for a
loop the holidays
lots of my go-to gifts are non-starters
this year can't send anybody to concerts
not sending anybody out dining movies
none of that
after everything that's happened this
year i want to get everyone on my list a
gift that will actually make them go hey
thanks i needed this i'm actually going
to use this my silver bullet gift idea
raycon wireless earbuds all right i tell
you about them all the time
i use them use them every day i had a
second pair
that i tell you all the time my stepson
took will not give him back because he
absolutely loves them
and i don't blame them i love mine too
they have seamless bluetooth pairing
they're comfortable they're noise
isolating
you can start listening right out of the
box and keep listening for hours the
audio quality is amazing it's comparable
to what you get from other premium
brands except raycon start at half the
price
best of all this is something you can
use for all calls for music for work or
play at home or on the go it's the gift
that keeps on giving
and if you already have a pair of
wireless earbuds you know you need a
spare because kids steal them
raycon's being generous for the holidays
so on top of their everyday great prices
they're offering my listeners 15
off right now go to buy raycom.com
honeydew today to get 15 off your raycon
order that's by raycon dot com slash
honeydew
by raycom.com honeydew
our next sponsor is hawthorne now i've
been thinking about making some personal
changes lately and i wanted to start by
improving my self-care routine you see
all
i grew this hair out over quarantine i
don't know if that happened
if we weren't locked down all right the
problem is i had no idea where to start
and then i found hawthorne hall thorn is
a premium tailored personal care brand
that's making easy for guys especially
like me to feel and smell your best so
you start with their quiz
okay they ask you things like you know
do you smoke what's your favorite drink
uh you know how do you like to spend the
night out stuff like that
and then they factor your answers into
the results okay so it was actually
really easy
and it was quick and i'd been asked
questions as a man i'd never been asked
before so
the products i got were deodorants i got
body washes i got
body sprays again taken
by my teenage stepson some of them i
wouldn't let them take all of them the
soaps everything's great
all right so if you want to upgrade your
self-care routine hall thorn's a fun and
convenient way to get super high quality
products tailored specifically for your
needs
hawthorne even takes the risk out of it
by giving you free shipping on your
order and returns
and if you don't like your products
they'll even retailer them for you based
on your feedback all right
so do what i did go take hawthorne's
quiz today and get started on your
personalized self-care routine
by going to hawthorne.co and use the
promo code honeydew to get 10 off your
first purchase okay
that's hawthorne.co and the promo code
is honeydew it's
great for christmas right now the
holidays yeah i've
uh sons boyfriends husbands whatever
especially yourself this is the package
to do it again hawthorne.co
promo code honeydew now let's get back
to the do
uh but uh what what was i gonna say uh
wow
you're dead but oh anyways what i was
getting at is i felt what indirect
racism felt like
because when we finally moved to tacoma
which is where my
my dad's side of the family moved back
and me saying this is probably going to
hurt my dad's feelings and it's probably
not even
100 true or accurate but i know
i felt it okay because i saw it when we
moved back
that's when the [ __ ] turmoil started
right everything was good man
you know my dad had a lot of stripes on
his on his arm he's making that master
sergeant money
you know what i mean my mom's working
part-time
we're we're living good the dollar is
strong in the philippines okay that's
so were you on base in the philippines
the last place before you came to the
states yeah
we're on base living that good life my
dad even had an extension
i remember that i remember we all cried
and we were so happy when he got the
extension because i did not want to
leave the philippines
you know i was there from like five to
like 11. yeah those are prime ministers
here in years man i remember riding the
bike and my mom just giving me like
three pesos and i could buy
a drip a sarcy like a soda basically
in a plastic bag and a straw and you're
so innocent you know you don't know what
poverty is you're just running with
the kids that's right seeing chickens in
the street you're seeing kids getting
bathed
you loved it the people touching you
because you're american you know what i
mean and
uh getting barbecue sticks and you just
buy it it's a peso eat it you don't
think about
fda regularly yeah regulations great do
you have it literally
is there an a rating can you imagine
asking somebody
they just rolled up a newspaper and set
it on fire and cooked
meat on the chicken right out of him is
there an egg
yeah we got it the best barbecue sticks
in the world
and just living that good life man and
then i remember moving back and it
[ __ ] ended bro and it was tacoma you
said tacoma it
ended and you know there's other things
that are deep with my family that that
uh
happen later on in life and that's why
another reason why i love my dad
so much because you know my brother has
mental illness problems and it came
when he was 15. and and uh what sort of
mental illness
he's you know he's got schizophrenia and
i have a cousin that has paranoia he's a
paranoid schizophrenic
my brother is uh he can
he can't work or let's just say you ever
watch that movie
glass is it glass the one with uh bruce
willis
oh you ever seen that look that up
can you look up glass with bruce willis
samuel jackson mr guy okay
there's amblin and then there's the
honeydew
by the way this is empty
oh well there's a character in that
movie that has schizophrenia
okay right but he's also a superhero
he's not a superhero but he has super
yes uh super strength
and my take on that movie i remember
watching that movie ryan and i got
chills watching it
because all i saw was my brother i was
like that's my brother
like this guy isn't really strong this
guy
is he's he's got a mental disorder yes
and in his world when my brother
goes into that world he can fight six
cops
and and and i've witnessed it i've seen
him have you seen that
bro really are you kidding me that's all
we
had was [ __ ] cops at the house every
[ __ ] week bro it it
[ __ ] sucked like nothing worse than
living in fear
right but also happy because you love
you love this person that's my big
brother
so he never messed with you guys though
right he always knew family no no no he
punched me once in a bed
he you know he you know he's done yeah
he's
awful he's kicked my dad he's my brother
can fight
that's the other thing he at 15 so
you're going through your
prime years yeah and he can fight yeah
my brother is always a fighter
you know what i mean and uh and my
brother is also street smart like he's
always been on the street so
he knows how to work the system you know
what i mean he he knows when he needs
help
you know and he knows how to get help
you know what i mean
yeah so uh and we figured him out but it
took a long time for us to figure him
out you know like when my brother's
homeless we're like
we get sad but then we're like he knows
what he's doing
you know what i mean he's getting his
fix and then he's gonna
he's gonna do what it takes to get into
jail and then he's also
he also knows that that's how he gets
into the hospital
but he also knows that's how he gets to
the hospital yeah and then he knows he's
got about six months worth of
shelter food and blah blah so we figured
out but for years it was always just us
walking on eggshells so you said
homeless so he would go missing at times
and you wouldn't know where he was or oh
yeah yeah my brother would just
disappear but then
you know we'd be sad but then we're also
like oh
you know like [ __ ] you know and see my
dad struggle and see and
like there were so many elements to why
i understood it didn't come till later
you know i had to be like in my mid-20s
almost 30 to really understand my dad
you know
but but then i understood like yo i
would have walked away
you know what i mean i would have that's
not my kid you know what i mean
yeah but then you go see the hospital
login book
you know you go you you go to my where
my brother stays
and you'll see jack herbert all the time
yeah
how about that
wow
you all right yeah
so are you do you talk to your dad now
are you guys close yeah i love my okay
i'm saying you you have open communicate
do you see each other
i told him that i told him that
ah i don't like doing that
but you know i'm glad you're doing it
but you know you uh you know you get it
you get it i appreciate my dad for that
yeah it's like but i would i've done
that [ __ ] no
that's what i'm saying you have
hindsight but you're also a dad
you're also a dad you could look at that
now and be like holy
[ __ ] how did you do it why did you do it
just the element just the element alone
of him like
fine you know getting a woman pregnant
that has two kids
and then adopting them in another
country as a
yeah you got to be a strong [ __ ]
yeah
and you know yeah he walked away but you
know
at how old where he walked away he
didn't walk away
know what i mean like he didn't have to
go visit my brother you know i mean no
no not even his kid like you said yeah
it's so i get it but like when i when i
say i saw racism
hand on like you know when we came back
to tacoma that's when [ __ ] started
happening my brother was going crazy
getting worse and um you know the cops
were coming more
um also i remember oh i just want to say
this
because i don't want to forget it
because i remember one christmas
where my dad went to to seattle
to see his parents and uh and he came
back with one gift
and it was for me right and my mom i
remember laying on the ground because i
always slept in my mom's room
you know i hated sleeping in my room so
i all slept in my mom's room
and uh i don't know if my mom and dad
were divorced but they were going
through some [ __ ]
so that's why he was going there and
then coming back whatever
and i remember he brought one gift back
uh for me for christmas
and he gave it to me and my mom took it
on my hand she goes if she if your
parents don't give
the other kids gifts then joe doesn't
give gifts
and then my dad was like oh come on
they're old enough they don't need
this for the kids christmas is for kids
and my mom was like [ __ ]
that that's that's not what this is
about
it's not about what age they are it's
christmas
you know what i mean they deserve gifts
too these are your kids
and i remember crying like oh what the
gift mama what the gift like there's
another part of ptsd right like i
remember that
but but now i get it my mom my mom was a
[ __ ] gangster
[ __ ] you yeah no no he doesn't get a
gift
and i'm glad she did that [ __ ] you know
but that was
that was that first sign i feel like
they were always
dude i gotta be careful what i say but i
feel like
you know the the kids not being fully
his
they they didn't really accept them
mm-hmm i'm not gonna say it's race
but i mean i just
in my eyes what else could have been
sure you know
well i wanted to ask you just as as an
asian family as well up in washington
like
during vietnam are you experiencing
racism from the white kids in school
are you talking about when i was when i
was
with the public schools um was it a
culture only when you went to like
out of the base bubble so you can live
on the base but you can also live
off the base oh so wait you were still
on base in tacoma
no but what i'm saying is you can live
off base gotcha but it's
it's but you're still debating got it
okay so you're surrounded with
still retired military by the way so the
community
looks you're not just out amongst the
civilians and even if they
are not part of military life they uh
they're they're surrounded by it because
that's the that's the main
source of income and you know that's
what the economy bill is built on is
that those bases
and you know i live by the army navy
like we lived next to every single base
yeah you know i mean they were all there
marines it was like the stronghold you
know what i mean
and uh it was when you went out into the
city
so when you went into tacoma that's when
you're kind of like the [ __ ] is this
you know right like what is this a cast
whatever you guys shooting a oh [ __ ]
are you guys are you shooting comedy
[Music]
[Laughter]
[ __ ] is this a bunch of those white
people
walking around the ball oh so uh
yeah so yeah i mean it was it was weird
yeah i did experience
like i said that's where that happened
tacoma mall when i saw that kid pull his
eyes back
like i experienced that or just seeing
tiger woods you know not get treated the
way he did i just knew that society
wasn't ready for something like that you
know it was black and white heroes in
in uh in sports yeah and and and and to
to get that one dominate the way it did
and and
and smash the [ __ ] masters
yeah you know what i mean and the way he
that he did
of course black people wanted to write
that
why wouldn't they [ __ ] we've
been caddies our whole life we could
only be on this course with a white suit
on
we had to wear a white jumpsuit with our
[ __ ] with the the golfers
get my red nikes now they're like my
sunday night
our dude yeah that's our dude he's black
and then tiger is well i mean no i'm not
all black
you know what i mean and people got
offended by that but but like
he was like he was right i got him he's
right mommy's half of him yeah that's
right
half of everything i'm also asian
look at my eyes yeah so and but that's
how i also felt like
identity was crazy for me people always
ask me like yo why do you always talk
about your mom on stage who the [ __ ] am
i supposed to talk about not only that
who am i supposed to i do want to talk
about your mom because now as a father
as and how many kids do you just have is
it your son
um yeah i have my son and uh
and you know it's so crazy because the
[ __ ] that my mom went through that's
what i'm saying like
how could you not talk about a woman
that raised four kids
by herself by herself one with
you know a mental disorder yeah in and
out of which is possible and like i've
said i've dealt with that and watched my
aunt deal with that and i know that is
dude i remember we never went i remember
we were driving to see my grandma who
lived in vegas so we drove from
uh washington all the way to vegas right
and i remember my brother went
nuts on my mom at a restaurant and he
was like give me all give me all my
[ __ ] money
because she was holding on to his money
and you know i think part of the deal
was
gonna help out on the gas and all that
[ __ ] i remember my mom giving him the
money and him leaving i was just like
like [ __ ] us you know
i don't even think atms were around yet
you know what i mean
there goes your money i think we were
still pay phones at that point
i was just like [ __ ] dude like i still
didn't get it because i didn't know what
it was
like what what is my brother dealing
with i don't know what that is
yet but i know it's just not right and i
was just like [ __ ] i remember us being
depressed on the car ride home
a car right there it's just like seeing
my mom go through that [ __ ] i was like
god dude like
my mind you my dad's not around you know
when did he leave you what age
11 to 11 okay yeah and and and
and ryan like i always have to explain
like
identity crisis right like like
imagine like being half white with hazel
eyes but saying i'm filipino
and the reason why is because i can't
say i'm white
yeah i don't even know my grandparents
like like
when like i don't know if you heard me
earlier i go his parents when he went to
see his parents like who says that
you know what i mean like whenever i see
my dad i go you know how's your dad
when you're growing up dad how's your
mom growing like i don't say grandma
i don't have any identity there's no
identity there i never know my dad
i met them but there was never this sure
it wasn't there man there was something
pulling us apart
yeah you know there was tension like
when we moved my dad already
my dad's decision to move out was the
minute we got there
and um and you know so who else like
when my mom was doing all these
you know i do this joke on you know on
my last special about
you know there was no facebook or
twitter back then
you know when my mom went to look for
filipinos
she literally went up to brown people
that looked like her and was like
filipino literally
and then a mexican be like actually
dad nevermind i'm so sorry i am so sorry
about that
it's just looking for something like me
embraced
to embrace and listen and understand
[Laughter]
the trauma i'm going through oh you're
for a moment yeah
let's take a quick break and tell you
about our next sponsor liquid iv all
right now the season's changing it's
getting cooler
you're making adjustments to your daily
routines your daily workouts maybe
you're bundling up out there with more
layers of clothes
and the cooler weather makes it easier
to miss signs dehydration like
overheating or perspiration
which means it's even more important to
keep your body properly hydrated with
one stick of liquid iv and 16 ounces of
water
you get two to three times the amount of
hydration as plain water okay
maybe you have holiday plans you know
you're not going to eat well
stay hydrated all right i've been on
home school this stuff been wearing me
down mentally i pop a couple of these a
day
and i'm telling you you feel amazing flu
season often lines up with the holiday
plans but liquid iv can help support
your immune system with increased
hydration
and essential vitamins it's perfect for
staying hydrated on holiday flights
long road trips uh it can even help with
hangovers after those extra holiday
drinks and that's true
i'm telling you right now it definitely
works on hangovers liquid iv's
best-selling hydration multiplier now
has three new flavors there's guava
watermelon
and apple pie all right i like liquid iv
i use it
like i said every day uh watermelon is
my favorite one right now they got a lot
of flavors
but i get up in the morning it's the
first thing i drop in some water
get my hydration back up and then even
just whenever whenever i'm feeling it i
just put it in a glass of water
drink it and i feel great one serving of
liquid iv
provides the same hydration as drinking
two to three bottles of water alone
it's healthier than sugary sports drinks
there's no artificial flavors or
preservatives and there's less sugar
than an apple okay it's made with clean
ingredients non-gmo vegan and free of
gluten dairy and soy
what makes liquid iv so effective the
cellular transportation technology the
optimal ratio of glucose sodium
and potassium delivers water and
nutrients into the bloodstream liquid iv
is also on a mission to change the world
they're a great company
in response to kova 19 products are
being donated to hospitals first
responders food banks
veterans active us military there's over
3 million servings in total so far
liquid iv is available nationwide at
walmart in the beverage section but why
are you going out to walmart we're
supposed to be social distances
anyway so do the safe thing do the smart
thing and save some money you'll get 25
off when you go to liquidive.com and you
use the code honeydew at checkout
that's 25 off of anything you order when
you use the promo code honeydew
at liquid iv.com get better hydration
today at liquidive.com
promo code honeydew our next sponsor is
keeps now as guys so much of our
identity is wrapped up in our hair
from how it feels after getting a fresh
cut to the way it's perfectly styled
before going out that's why when we get
into our 20s and 30s start noticing the
first signs of hair loss
it definitely feels like panic time
because let's face it no guy is ever
ready to go bald but thankfully now
there's keeps the simple and easy way to
keep your hair
did you know that two out of three guys
experience some form of male pattern
baldness by the time they're 35
the best way to prevent hair loss is to
do something about it while you still
have
your hair left alright you used to have
to go to the doctor's office for your
hair loss prescription not anymore now
thanks to keeps
you can visit a doctor online and get
hair loss medication delivered
right to your home they make it easy and
they deliver your medication every three
months so you can say goodbye to
pharmacy checkout lines and awkward
doctor visits alright
keeps also offers generic versions of
the only two fda approved hair loss
products out there you may have tried
them before
but probably never for this price find
out why keeps has more five star reviews
than any of its competitors and more
than a hundred thousand men
trust keeps for their hair loss
prevention medication keeps his
treatment start at just
ten dollars a month plus for a limited
time you can get your first month for
free
so here's what you gotta do all right if
you're ready to take action and prevent
hair loss go to keeps.com
honeydew to receive your first month of
treatment for free
that's k-e-e-p-s dot com
slash honeydew all right one more time
k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash honeydew now
let's get back to the do okay so this is
how my mom met filipinos
uh we we went to church a lot
and uh and you know you see filipinos
there
and uh and what ended up happening is
this filipino met that filipino and then
they became like this little community
of friends
and i don't know what this is but it's
called the knights of columbus
yeah and it's a hall that's usually
attached to a church right
i'm not very religious i don't even know
what though i know what the knights of
columbus are but i don't know what the
[ __ ] it is so the
columbus was this little
square building that was hollowed out is
for you to throw parties there but it
was attached to the
church and they would rent it out these
filipinos
you know their little dance hall yeah
there was no you know like it's so funny
because my son has filipino friends
there's filipino stars you know what i
mean there's there's filipino people in
the industry me
you know what i mean like that was that
didn't exist in the 80s man so there was
no filipino restaurant so
you know when i got filipino food is
when my mom decided to cook filipino
food
but man when we had a night to columbus
event and we did potluck
oh that was the [ __ ] bro
and everyone brought an item from that
ah i didn't want to [ __ ] leave man
we would literally use empty ice cream
containers or cool whip containers and
we would just
load it up i love your cool whip
tupperware yeah yeah
it was real like whatever was empty on
the table we would
you that's i think that's why they used
that because it was like
the tupperware stayed home and this
stuff you can give away and
and that's why like oh i remember just
loading it up like mom just take
grab it please mom she would grab one
sit and olympia would put in the big
neapolitan ice cream container just
loaded up and we would eat for a week
filipino food and um so that was our
little community of friends man
you know that's that's how we met
filipinos so my identity was that
that's all i knew that's why that's all
i talk about you know i want to talk
about my dad's side but
what can i possibly talk about you know
who do you it doesn't suck who did you
have male role models when your dad
likes
who did you look up to okay you love
that dude dude so when did he look up to
my dad he's my
he's my dad he's a beautiful man you
know now now that i'm a father
and uh i understand schizophrenia and
all this [ __ ]
bro i love my dad dude i want to be that
guy you know what i mean i want to
do to be able to you know he lived in
arizona dude to have a log book like i'd
love to show you this log book you have
it
no no it's a it's a log book in the
hospital that's there yeah and if you
see it bro you were like whoa he was
there all the time
bro and never
it's cool it is
yeah take a seat put some [ __ ] water
in here so i could actually
swallow the [ __ ] whole bottle over
there don't you have any
oh yeah you do have a whole bottle
thanks
it's from the other guests
[Music]
the [ __ ] producer goes let me clean
the cup he goes hold on before we start
going to clean the cup and when he came
back
he goes here i go are your fingers in
the [ __ ] cup
it's yeah but clean on the other side
drink on the other side
all right sorry but comedy comedy is my
comedy i'm very emotional right i know i
am as well
and comedy was my outlet right so i knew
i was funny
right away right away like when i was in
the philippines i i was like five
six seven like my mom and dad would
literally make me entertain
you know like it was always joking oh
joseph do that one thing that you do
do that you know and i'll do it you know
and uh
and i i knew i i had something right it
wasn't until i got to tacoma
and uh my my neighbor goes
oh you should be a comedian i remember
him saying that and you were you were
little then huh yeah i was like 10 11.
you know you should be a comedian dude
like and i was like what
what's that like you know meet a guy on
stage and tell
like richard pryor dude and his dad i
remember his dad how all these rich
priorities gave me the rich pride i fell
i remember listening to that [ __ ] my mom
let me listen to anything that was my
mom's number one rule
uh this is why i love my mom so much she
goes uh
you can curse all you want just don't
curse at me
say whatever you want but you say it to
me
we have a problem you respect me yeah
and she was right because it's just
words yeah it's when you when you
when you have conviction and meaning
behind it then it's then it's bad
so my mom let us curse she loved it man
i got to watch dirty [ __ ]
what stage does your stepfather come
into your life um
he came into my life when i was uh dude
i was 15
16. i was a sophomore in high school
so 16 and he's a good man dude this is
what i love about it let me tell about
were you resistant to it at all bro oh
yeah of course you are okay
you [ __ ] my mom bro the [ __ ]
out of here soldier saul he's a soldier
that's right he's [ __ ] my mom
soldier what's his name friend
sergeant frederick harrison let's hear
about sergeant sergeant frederick
harrison
sergeant frederick harrison is six foot
two
and just a [ __ ] war hero bro he's a
not a war hero he's a war he's a war
anybody who goes to war is a [ __ ]
hero
when you say hero like you save a life
but he did protect this
you know he fought for this country guys
right and uh and let me tell you what
this dude has man he's got two purple
hearts
and a bronze star damn so by the way
they don't give bronze stars uh
no like that you know i mean it's that's
a
very special thing in fact i don't even
think they give them away anymore
and uh and to get one purple heart
people gotta understand you gotta get
hurt in combat to get a purple heart
yeah you got to be at war and and and
that's
not tipping out of your desk chair and
[ __ ] banging your head and [ __ ]
no respect the hallway on base yeah
you ain't getting the purple and you got
a purple heart don't tell anyone you got
it
just just enjoy it for yourself all
right [ __ ]
no no no all my soldiers i love you uh
they're just jokes
um but seriously don't tell anyone um
sergeant frederick harrison was in the
[ __ ]
he was in the pits bro you know i mean
he's he's a grunt
right he's a marine no he's army army
okay
he's a grunt uh i was just [ __ ] with
you
um
you heard that uh he was a grunt
and which means give him [ __ ]
gun and go in yeah
we drop you yes that's it you're going
first too you're going first
keep your socks dry yeah and that's a
real thing keep your socks dry
because it's gonna be a while before you
get some socks
and uh in the rain forest right uh and
we'll
we'll drop some weed out for you guys to
keep you happy
but uh don't tell anyone that we dropped
weed here is that what they would they
would drop it for him yeah he was
smoking weed of course like
would you want some weed yeah oh i would
and um so uh god damn it i don't want to
lose the story oh
so anyways from the hills of uh from the
mountains of west virginia this soldier
came from
my guys as a west virginia boy that's
why i fell in love with major harris you
know
west virginia the volunteer i love
that's my team man i love them are you
wvu guy i love them all right i've been
i've partied there yeah
okay um so i love west virginia i only
went there once
i'll never live there yeah but i love
i love it because that's where sergeant
frederick harrison came from and uh
he um 17 years old bro
he uh i i even asked him i go dude 17
years old and you enlisted in the army
he goes bubba he goes uh
i had to i had to get out of west
virginia bubble and i go
why why why would you choose
war then you had an out you're 17.
you still had a year before he even had
to enter the draft
why he goes bobo
i was tired of [ __ ] in the snow
it is
all his uncles died in the coal mine
they all died a black lung yeah you go
down into the coal with a bird bubble
they give you a bird bubble that bird
dies you run bubble
that's what you do that's [ __ ] like
what they do they give you a bird
the bird just died i don't know
hey hey our candles just burnt out for
no reason yeah get them go
um yeah and um
he 17 he goes he goes i was tired of
[ __ ] in the snow bubble
and i'm like yo this is a true story by
the way i go
what the [ __ ] and of course he's trying
to be he's trying to be funny
but he goes he goes you have a bubba
yeah
i have to [ __ ] in the snow
in the middle of winter on the mountain
with no with no uh what is it called
a central plumbing home bubble we had
outhouses bubba
you got to dig a hole you ever try and
dig a hole in the ice while holding your
[ __ ]
you hit the ice you hit the ice wrong
and the [ __ ] fly out your ass
now you're just covering the [ __ ]
you got to do this character dude you
got to do this character
you got it down dude i love it your
voice has changed
i love fred so much
you know i thought i thought boo i
thought boo came from
uh rap i thought that was a nickname for
rap
for from rappers like hey boo hey boo
you know what i mean ain't that right
boo true
bro that is such a mountain term like
that he used to call us boo boo like hey
boo
like hey boo he'll say it to like and i
was like oh that is some
that's some hill holy [ __ ] yeah that's
country [ __ ]
you know what i mean and uh uh yeah so
he was serious he goes uh bubba ah
i'm giving too much because uh it's so
funny that you're saying this because
this is what i want to talk about in my
next special but uh
because i do want to do it and this is
actually some stuff that i want to talk
about but anyways
that's why he said i i was tired of
[ __ ] in
the snow bubba it's rough that's a rough
lap bubba
and uh and he joined the military and he
joined he joined to be in
uh to fight the war he knew it was for
the war and he had no skill sets
he just said i could fight i could shoot
seventeen [ __ ] dude hunts
i could i could shoot a gun and uh
sent them in right away dropped him in
shrapnel
[ __ ] platoon gets hit shrapnel hits
his whole left side
damn so left side hold right side whole
left side his whole left side of his
body
just metal fragments dude he's got all
these scars dude
take it out all up and down his right uh
left side
17 bro you got to see the pictures he
looks like a little boy i know i think
of myself it's
yeah right it's my son's step-son only
only
seven only six foot two that's but it's
still my son
like i'm looking at his face like oh my
god you're a baby friend and he's got
his
gurney he's holding a little iv bottle
this back not iv bag iv
bottle yeah [ __ ] it
it's got medicine and then when it's
empty it's got liquor in it
so it was in the 60s oh
um and then uh and then they they they
came and
brought him a purple heart while he was
in there gave him the purple heart and
then you go you free to go home soldier
and this [ __ ] this is how crazy
he is he goes
i don't want [ __ ] in the snow and he
stays put me back in
no way swear to god bro
to the holy [ __ ] him back in i don't
know if it was uh eight months later or
whatever it was
he gets shot by a sniper right what ba
[ __ ] hits him over his right shoulder
right entry wound is about the size of a
dime he's got a
hole right here a little dime-like uh
hole whole front side just gone
[ __ ] gone shoulder droops over like
this this is how he you know his
his whole shoulder droops like that
still now like that's from the injury
yeah yeah yeah you know back then in the
60s you get shot they just scrape
out whatever and then sold out see you
later yeah you know
and uh and then they uh put a purple
heart and then they gave him the bronze
star
and they were like soldier you free to
go home and uh and that's when he was
like yeah i need to go
i'm gonna go [ __ ]
[Laughter]
it took two injuries
so that's the price of [ __ ] in the
snow yeah
and he's a bad [ __ ] so he's a
bad
[ __ ] bro he's and he's always a
fifth of [ __ ]
fifth of jack like it's nothing a pack
a pack of smokes a pack of marble reds
you know what i mean came into my life
when i was 15. at what age did you start
to accept him
i mean it was right away i fell in love
because that was that man
yeah male figure was in the house
finally yeah i was missing for like four
years
five years and also being tormented
by my brother and then all of a sudden
my mom starts dating this guy but what i
loved about him is that he loved the
seahawks but he also loved the redskins
he loved the dodgers i remember when the
dodgers played the mets
and i was such a dwight gooden fan yeah
right daryl strawberry and you know
everyone
jumped on that bandwagon you know what i
mean because and uh especially when
you're a young kid you're just like oh
look at this
[ __ ] daryl strawberry he's so cool
looking
and then and you know of course fred
loved
the dog he was always a dodger fan you
know and i remember i bet him uh
uh i think i bet him like 50 bucks or
something i didn't even have the money
but i was just like 50 bucks at dodgers
uh dodgers gonna lose fred
was it against the mets who they play
look it up
whoever they played um but i remember
when he played uh when the dodgers no it
could have been the mets because no
you talk about world series the world
series when the when the dodgers played
the world series i remember i was a mets
fan
and then all of a sudden the dodgers are
in the world series right and then i i
remember betting
i was like [ __ ] lose like bubba dog's
gonna kick that ass
this is a true story and uh and i was
like nah nah and i remember
i don't know what game it came down to
but it was kirk gibson
yeah yeah [ __ ] kirk gibson home
run and i bet to extend it yeah and i
bet fred that's the bet
you bet him on that kirk and then kurt
gibson
and frank didn't give a [ __ ] he had to
love that did not give a [ __ ]
he was just like he's such a dodger fan
i remember him like you you put your
money where your mouth
is bubba you think they're gonna win go
ahead better put your money where your
mouth is bubba
and uh and uh and that [ __ ] curt gets
knocked it out
i told you you better pay me back and
i've never paid them back until just
like recently
at least you
[Laughter]
you should have bought them a toilet
yeah yeah i shoulda
but that was a smell yeah but that was
the chemistry man it was just like this
sports chemistry he was a lakers fan i
remember he got this credit card for the
first time
like when uh it was his first credit
card you know he was out
he never had a credit card wow because
he was he was a [ __ ] up
yeah he's not [ __ ] up but he was a
millionaire he was a soldier boy they
weren't [ __ ]
worried about credit and establishing
all he got his credit card and then he
was like hey let's go shopping bubba
and he took me shopping i was like what
he bought me a corduroy laker hat
and he bought me a just do it nike tank
top i got a pizza remember that [ __ ] oh
hell yeah dude
oh and you bought me a just do it fanny
pack isn't it funny what sticks with you
when when
people connect with you yeah well i also
remember that because we didn't have
[ __ ]
i never had that stuff i didn't start
getting you know he was the one that
started doing that for me but
um but i just remember but he used to
drink a lot and i used to laugh
you know because we didn't get drunk he
was a he's he was a happy drunk
you know i mean he was a happy drunk but
he was also annoying because he'd slur
it's bad enough i didn't understand what
he said when he wasn't drunk but now he
is drunk
and uh but anyways um i wrecked his van
i didn't get my i didn't get my uh
driver's license
i was supposed to pass the test he was
gonna let me drive to prom and uh and i
didn't get it and i remember we sat on
the balcony he goes
he goes whatever you do don't drink and
drive but i'm gonna give you the keys
bubba
and he gave me the keys and i [ __ ]
hit a hot fire hydrant
he's so he let you drive illegally you
[ __ ] it up
night the worst night to let a teenager
drive and he gave me the keys
i got shot twice bubba it definitely is
the worst night
right he's the [ __ ] dude they used to
put that wrecked car out in front of our
heights
scare you into it you know like this is
what can happen we'd be like holy [ __ ]
rent a limo yeah but here's the so so
all these years of seeing uh
my dad struggle with my brother get into
fist fights and and not
and not you know i'll put it out there
didn't
declare victory ever with my brother he
went defeated yeah yeah he went defeated
sad uh but but you're by the way it's a
different
it's a different person you know and uh
and you also don't want to hurt a young
you know yeah [ __ ] it no my dad got my
ass kicked
um and uh
and then all of a sudden we're in this
apartment in tacoma
and my and fred's staying over he's been
staying over a lot by the way
and here comes my [ __ ] brother like
clockwork bro
just kick in the door it's like seven
o'clock in the morning
big metal door right and i wake up i'm
like well
i'm looking down the hallway my sister's
looking down the hallway and we just
hear open the door
mind you my brother's not big he's like
five five but he'll kick your ass
he'll beat the [ __ ] out yeah he's got
that strength scary bro like i said mr
glass bro
that movie that whatever that character
was that's what i saw
i saw a [ __ ] dude with super
superhuman strength like
yeah that's a metal door but my
brother's about to kick it open it's
about it's about to happen
soon and here it comes bam that [ __ ]
door
flies open and and then he starts
walking
and it's scary bro he's scared and i
mean around like [ __ ]
he's like he's like he's back his
friend's staying there
and fred's already in the hallway and
he's like i'm telling you right now
bubba i don't want to fight
yeah mike and he's got an army yeah all
right yeah
yeah but bro seeing fred stand up
to robert was already like
i was like seeing i was seeing like god
like
oh [ __ ] right and he's like bubba i
don't want to fight you bubba
i'm just telling you turn around right
now bubba just leave
just leave and rob was like [ __ ] you
now like here it comes bro right throws
a punch you throw on the right
and then fred just [ __ ]
linebacker by the way he played
linebacker yeah yeah uh
when he was a in high school
slammed him down [ __ ] so i i remember
hearing my brother go
and robert just punch him from the
pom-pom but
and fred's this is how cool fred is
doesn't throw a punch
he was well he's like bubba i'm 250
pounds
i'm 250 pounds but i ain't moving i
ain't moving
he goes he goes uh you can punch all you
want bubba i ain't moving
i'm staying right here and then robert
starts
it but but by at this point robert's
just like let me up
let me know i'm gonna let you up bubba
but you better just walk out this door
but that's all we doing
all right all right all right let me up
he [ __ ] gets up
by the way i've seen my brother take six
cops yeah you were saying yeah
i see my guys got a one and a half let
me let me explain to you
what i've seen and this is this is when
right when we got to tacoma
i've seen my brother being laid out like
this crucifix style right with his arms
like this one cop on this arm
another cup on this arm another guy with
his knee on my brother's back
right and they're just trying give me
the [ __ ] arm
right another cop like standing there
you know me give me the [ __ ] arm all
right give me the [ __ ] arm
[ __ ] you you want the arm take the
[ __ ] arm
by hitting him in the back of the head
i'm like robert get the [ __ ] arm just
give me [ __ ]
crying [ __ ] you always good i give him
the [ __ ] arm like you're just looking
at like
that's the kind of [ __ ] i suck yeah and
you see that [ __ ] like rory
i didn't want to see my brother get beat
up give me your [ __ ] arm
i ain't giving my [ __ ] you better
take my [ __ ] arm
bro it's crazy [ __ ] like that so seeing
this
was like what the [ __ ]
you know what i mean and then your
brother get up and then my brother got
up talking [ __ ]
right talking [ __ ] and he's walking on
[ __ ] you i better never see you outside
outside
just walk out bubba walk out i think i
think fred was bigger than 250 at that
point
i thought fred was like 262 like he was
a big man he had the big
belly bro yeah he was a big [ __ ] man
just walk out bro walk out bubba just go
ahead walk out all right but i'll see
you in the street bubba i'll see you
know that condescending tone
don't worry i'll just [ __ ] tackle you
there too yeah
and then we got to the door and he goes
just walk down the steps
cough and then just walk down the steps
just walk downstairs bubba and he's
my brother starts about to go down and
then he [ __ ] turns around
no yeah turns around and throws another
punch i think he hits fred in the arm
because you gotta remember my brother's
small
so he swings up hits fred in the arm
fred grabs his arm
or something i forget what happened but
then fred takes the bad arm
no and [ __ ]
on the side here's the command
[ __ ] friend
and that was it robert i remember robert
[ __ ]
i think that shocked him and then and
then robert
uh you know he walked down the stairs
and you know yelling and all that [ __ ]
but then he walked away
and that was it i was like this is the
dude
this is the [ __ ] dude right that's
great yeah man and that was
yeah that's why i love yo i love fred so
much man that's that's my
that's my guy man so yeah he came into
my life and
he and he changed it as well you know
that's awesome
yeah well you changed mine look you did
i'm telling you you don't know that
but i'm telling you that episode it
really made me
think differently it made me calm down
it made me like
all right it was still new to me at the
time so i was like all right we got a
process here let's get through this
let's try to do the best we can
so we got to get you out of here oh but
i want to ask you a question
i asked you i'm so happy you're making
it good with your your ex i'm trying
it's so important to your
your kids yeah it is it really is man do
it
like suck it the [ __ ] up i know it's ego
is what i have to worry i try to kill my
ego
daily i do yeah and remember man your
your
your kids write their story yep they'll
figure it out you ain't got to tell them
everything nothing you don't have to say
anything that's right
they will write it they will [ __ ]
write it and they will know what's right
and they'll know what's wrong
they'll know through action yeah you
know i mean so and not only that
but my ex-wife man [ __ ] amazing and
who else better to watch your kids than
your ex
yeah you know i mean so like just that
that family unit even though you guys
aren't together
it's it's an amazing my mom's the one
that said it which is even crazier
you know because she said three yeah but
but but the [ __ ] that my dad
and her went through and for her to look
at me and go because i was taking my
dad's side
like i'm not sighed i was becoming my
dad in the divorce
like i was ready to move away i'll see
myself when i come back
and this is the money you're getting and
you know
three months i'll come get like i was
that attitude give him [ __ ]
and then i was like my mom was like what
are you doing like
you remember how you felt when you
didn't see your dad and i'm like yeah
do you want your son to feel that and i
started crying i was like oh [ __ ]
yeah yeah and that was it all right so
let me ask you this i ask everyone that
comes on this is so emotional the last
question you've done
honeydew what's sweet about this you
call this sour but won't you call it
bitter melon
advice you would give to yours looks
delicious tastes like [ __ ]
what advice after everything we've
talked about what advice would you give
to your 16 year old self
and we'll end on that oh
um you had a lot going on at that time
this is the i will only tell my
myself one thing uh be more confident
but i was dealing with a lot of
depression bro i'm friends with a couple
of
well i'm actually only friends with one
per
person from my my junior high school
uh years which was my lowest of low and
when you live in tacoma it's
you know it can get depressing because
of the weather right
and when you're going through some [ __ ]
you you tend to think about a lot of
stuff and there was some [ __ ]
where i was like god man like i [ __ ]
hate it like i used to
walk around with my head down you know
and and my shoulders used to always
slouch i think i
even walk the same way i think it's so
inspiring because you are
nothing like that now and to to come
from that
for yourself to do the self work and to
be who you are now that's amazing for
people today comedy saved my life
same i i bro and i had a vcr tape
uh that i you know you could press uh
eplp
or sp long play extended play
and i remember if you went to extended
play you get six hours on the tape
that's right
and i could get six hour specials on
that [ __ ] and uh and i remember one had
uh
it had uh it had robin williams live
from the met i have whoopi goldberg
around the world and i forget what it
was called 18 [ __ ] days
it had bill cosby himself delirious it
had uh
louis anderson on i am uh yeah i
remember
just always watching that [ __ ] you know
because we didn't have cable i i
i would have to find a way to get it i
remember when my mom got hbo that's when
i was like
i couldn't wait to watch i would make my
a bigger collection but i remember
getting that i would take that tape and
record it right and i had it and watch
it all the time
and and i literally watch it all the
time man rewind it watch it rewind it
watch it rewind and watch it and
and that's where it all came from man um
so yeah comedy scene in my life more
confident
be yo confidence it's it's everything
look up there's this instagram video of
this kid
that went to go dunk i saw it i love it
i watch it all the time
he's got his head and his friend and bro
it's amazing and that means a lot it bro
stand straight and look i i make my bed
every single day
like my house would be [ __ ] dirty but
i remember fred telling me
don't leave this house bubba without
that with that bed dirty
a messy bed is a messy life now go clean
your bed true
and i've yes sir and i haven't stopped
doing my bed
same i remember i took a shower and i
was about to go to my pod today and i
went to the room i said oh [ __ ] i forgot
and i gave a [ __ ] i was gonna be late
but i didn't give a [ __ ]
fix it yeah they texted me you were
running late yeah
i was about to be late to the other pod
[ __ ] i got here on time
you did you did well brother thank you
so much i love you babe
i love you too do you want to promote
anything no no no all right
thank you you know what we did all this
we didn't even get to your leg come back
and tell the legs story because i want
to hear it let's go
uh as always
man do you feel that shake the building
does that happen all the time
no that was crazy
whoa that shook the building uh as
always ryan sickler.com ryan sickler on
all social media we'll talk to you all
next week
[Music]